LAST WEEK...
(LAUGHTER)
OH, (BLEEP) JUST GOT REAL.
LAST WEEK, THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION AND IRAN IN
COOPERATION WITH RUSSIA, FRANCE,
BRITAIN, GERMANY AND CHINA,
REACHED AN HISTORIC
OUTLINE OF A FRAMEWORK
OF AN OUTLINE OF A
POTENTIAL DRAFT FOR A PRE-FINAL
TENTATIVE NUCLEAR DEAL
ARRANGEMENT!
PENDING APPROVAL.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
BUT FIRST, CONGRESS HAS SOME
CONCERNS.
>> THIS DEAL DOESN'T DISMANTLE
ONE CENTRIFUGE, IT DOESN'T CLOSE
ONE SITE.
>> NO ONE TRUSTS IRAN.
>> I DON'T TRUST THE LEADERSHIP
OF IRAN.
>> THERE SHOULD HAVE BEEN A
CLEAR RECOGNITION ON THEIR PART
THAT ISRAEL HAS A RIGHT TO
EXIST AS A JEWISH STATE.
>> I WOULDN'T HAVE STARTED THESE
NEGOTIATIONS TO BEGIN WITH.
>> Jon: WHAT!
SO I GUESS WE'RE GIVING CEDING
TO LIARS AND ANTI-SEMITES IN A
NEGOTIATION THAT NEVER
SHOULD HAVE EXISTED BUT
OTHER THAN THAT,
GOOD FIRST DRAFT.
WHAT COURSE OF ACTION IF NOT A
TREATY WOULD CONGRESS RECOMMEND?
>> SOMETHING ALONG THE LINES OF
WHAT PRESIDENT CLINTON DID IN
DECEMBER 1998, SEVERAL DAYS OF
AIR AND NAVAL BOMBING
AGAINST IRAQ'S WEAPONS OF MASS
DESTRUCTION FACILITIES.
>> Jon: OH, RIGHT!
1998, CLINTON SENT MISSILES IN
THERE IN OPERATION I GUESS
THAT'S THAT.
(LAUGHTER)
YEAH, THAT 1998 BOMBING FIXED
IRAQ FOREVER, TRANSITIONING THAT
COUNTRY FROM A DICTATORSHIP
TO AN AMERICAN-LOVING
KITTEN-AND-FUDGE-BASED
DEMOCRACY.
EVERYONE LOVES A
KITTEN-AND-FUDGE-BASED
--DEMOCRACY. BUT THE TRUTH
IS, EVEN IF THE SENATORS --
(LAUGHTER)
REALLY? HONESTLY, JUST ADDED A
[BLEEP] T. THAT'S ALL WE DID.
EVEN IF THE SENATORS DID THINK
THE DEAL WITH IRAN WAS A GOOD
DEAL, THE SENATORS WOULD STILL
HAVE TO FULFILL THEIR
CONSTITUTIONAL OBLIGATION.
>> NO SENATE OR HOUSE SHOULD
EVER LET ANY PRESIDENT DO AWAY
WITH CONGRESSIONAL SANCTIONS
CREATED BY THE BODIES WITHOUT
THEIR APPROVAL.
>> I THINK IT'S CRITICAL THAT IS
SENATE APPROVE THIS LIKE WE
DO ANY TREATY.
>> IT REQUIRES THE ADVICE AND
CONSENT OF THE UNITED STATES
SENATE.
>> Jon: SLOW DOWN THERE, McCAIN!
SENATE'S ALREADY IN SESSION,
LIKE, THREE DAYS A MONTH!
(LAUGHTER)
YOU DON'T WANT TO OVERLOAD YOUR
SCHEDULE, BLOW A GASKET.
OF COURSE!
THE CONSTITUTION ALSO GIVES
CONGRESS THE RESPONSIBILITY TO
DECLARE WAR.
HOW CONCERNED ARE THEY WITH
DEFENDING THAT AUTHORITY FROM
PRESIDENTIAL OVERREACH?
>> I DON'T WANT TO LIMIT OUR
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF.
>> THIS RESOLUTION SAYS WIN A
WAR, IT TAKES GROUND TROOPS
WHEREVER IT TAKES.
>> A GUY NAMED RONALD REAGAN
INVADED A SOVEREIGN, SMALL
SOVEREIGN NATION CALLED
GRENADA, YOU KNOW, AND NOTIFIED
EVERYBODY THE NEXT MORNING
AFTER, AFTER IT WAS COMPLETED.
>> CONGRESS SHOULD SORT OF SHUT
UP.
>> Jon: THE PRESIDENT NEEDS TO
FOCUS, EVERYBODY!
HE'S BOMBING PEOPLE!
MY ADVICE IS THAT CONGRESS
CONSENT TO A HOT CUP OF SHUT
THE (BLEEP) UP!
DELAWARE!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
DELAWARE, WHEN THE PRESIDENT'S
BOMBING PEOPLE, YOU SO MUCH SAY
A WORD I WILL SHOVE YOU SO FAR
UP MASSACHUSETTS' ASS, YOU WILL
SMELL MAINE!
(LAUGHTER)
A LOT OF THE TOUGH TALK FROM --
AS A MATTER OF FACT, CONGRESS IS
SO LAX IN THEIR WAR-MAKING
OVERSIGHT, THE PRESIDENT HIMSELF
IS SOMEWHAT UNCOMFORTABLE WITH
THE AMOUNT OF FIRE IN HIS POWER
LIKE HIS DRONE STRIKE AUTHORITY.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS WE'VE GOT
TO DO IS PUT A LEGAL
ARCHITECTURE IN PLACE AND WE
NEED CONGRESSIONAL HELP TO DO
THAT TO MAKE SURE THAT NOT ONLY
AM I REINED IN BUT ANY PRESIDENT
IS IN TERMS OF SOME OF THE
DECISIONS WE'RE MAKING.
>> Jon: STOP ME CONGRESS
BEFORE I KILL -- OH, TOO LATE.
TURNS OUT, WHEN IT COMES TO
BOMBING COUNTRIES OR SENDING
ADVISORS TO COUNTRIES OR DRONE
STRIKING COUNTRIES, CONGRESS IS
THE GIRL WHO JUST CAN'T SAY NO.
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO COOPERATING
WITH COUNTRIES, TREATIES -- HOLD
ON THERE!
WHAT ARE YOU DOING, MISTER?
LIKE THE SMALL ARMS TREATY TO
STOP THE ILLEGAL INTERNATIONAL
TRADE OF ARMS RATIFIED BY 66
OTHER COUNTRIES.
>> WHY IN THE WORLD WOULD
SOMEBODY WANT TO GIVE TO CEDE
TO THE UNITED NATIONS OR ANY
MULTI-NATIONAL GROUP THE POWER
TO MAKE DETERMINATIONS AS TO
WHOM, WITH WHOM WE TRADE ARMS.
>> THIS TREATY WILL INFRINGE ON
THE SECOND AMENDMENT RIGHTS OF
AMERICAN GUN OWNERS.
>> Jon: BLACK MARKET SOMALI
ARMS TRAFFICKING DOESN'T KILL
PEOPLE.
PEOPLE WHO BUY BLACK MARKET
SOMALI ARMS -- OH, FORGET IT!
(LAUGHTER)
OR THE LAW OF THE SEA TREATY
WHICH CREATES GUIDELINES FOR HOW
COUNTRIES CAN RESPONSIBLY USE
MARINE NATURAL RESOURCES,
RATIFIED BY 167 COUNTRIES OR
IT'S KNOWN, EARTH MINUS US.
>> WHAT IT DOES IN JUST A ONE
SENTENCE FORM IS TO RELINQUISH
OUR SOVEREIGNTY OVER 70% OF THE
WORLD.
>> Jon: WHAT ARE WE THE
SPANISH ARMADA?
AS YOU KNOW, AMERICA CURRENTLY
OWNS THE OCEANS.
EVER SINCE PRESIDENT NIXON BLEW
ON NEPTUNE'S FABLED CONCH SHELL
AND BECAME PRINCE OF THE DEEP!
(LAUGHTER)
OR -- AND THE ONE IS HONESTLY
HARD TO BELIEVE THAT WE WON'T
RATIFY, THE TREATY TO PROMOTE
RIGHTS FOR THE DISABLED
RATIFIED BY 153 NATIONS.
>> IN ALL HONESTY, I DON'T WANT
TO LOSE OUR SOVEREIGNTY IN THIS
ISSUE.
>> Jon: OH! I DON'T WANT SOME
ONE WORLD BLACK HELICOPTER
ILLUMINATI COMING HERE AND
TELLING US WHICH RAMP NEEDS
TO GO IN FRONT OF WHICH LIBRARY!
AND IT'S NOT ALWAYS THAT WE'RE
ALWAYS WORKING AGAINST OTHER
COUNTRIES, WE DO WORK WITH OTHER
COUNTRIES, WE DO IT ALL THE
TIME.
>> WELL, CERTAINLY WE NEED OTHER
PARTNERS.
I MEAN, WE NEED THESE OTHER ARAB
COUNTRIES TO STEP IN.
>> THE UNITED STATES MUST BE
COMMITTED TO BUILDING A
COALITION THAT ASSISTS THE
IRAQI, KURDISH AND FREE SYRIAN
FORCES.
>> DEMONSTRATE OUR COMMITMENT TO
THE GLOBAL COALITION IN
DEFEATING THIS RADICAL ISLAMIC
ORGANIZATION.
>> AMERICAN SOLDIERS NEED TO GO
BACK TO SYRIA AND IRAQ AS PART
OF THE COALITION --
>> Jon: SEE?
YOU WANT TO WORK WITH THE UNITED
STATES, HUH?
WELL, THERE'S ONLY TWO THINGS
YOU CAN DO WITH RAMPS -- BUILD
'EM OR BOMB 'EM.
(LAUGHTER)
AND I DON'T SEE NO BUILDING RAMP
MATERIALS.
(LAUGHTER)
WHICH BRINGS US TO THE QUESTION,
WHY ARE WE SO (BLEEP) CAUTIOUS
AND UNWILLING TO COOPERATE WITH
THE GLOBAL COMMUNITY ON
NON-MILITARY AGREEMENTS?
>> WHENEVER A BILL OR A TREATY
IS PASSED, THERE ARE SOME
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES.
>> LET'S DO IT WITHOUT ENMESHING
OUR NATION INTO ANOTHER BINDING
INTERNATIONAL ORGANIZATION THAT
WILL CAUSE MORE GRIEF THAN
BENEFIT.
>> YOU ALSO NEED TO PAY VERY
CAREFUL ATTENTION TO THOSE
CONSEQUENCES THAT ARE UNINTENDED
BECAUSE THAT IS WHERE THE DANGER
TRULY LIES.
>> Jon: YES, THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF TRYING TO MAKE
PEACE!
OUR CONGRESS IS INCREDIBLY
CAUTIOUS ABOUT TREATIES BECAUSE
YOU NEVER KNOW THE BLOW-BACK
PEACEFUL COOPERATION CAN HAVE!
WE SEE IT ALL THE TIME!
MAYBE IF WE HADN'T BEEN SO
EAGER TO COLLECT HALLOWEEN
PENNIES FOR UNICEF, IRAQ WOULD
BE A STABLE COUNTRY TODAY.
AND I.S.I.S. WOULD NEVER GET A
FOOTHOLD.
BUT THAT'S THE KIND OF GOODNESS
BAKED INTO OUR CONSTITUTION, TO
MAKE PEACE, TWO-THIRDS OF THE
SENATE NEED TO COME ALONG.
YOU WANT TO GO TO WAR, THOUGH?
SIMPLE MAJORITY.
AND A QUICK TIP IF YOU CALL IT
SOMETHING ELSE, YOU CAN DO
WHATEVER THE (BLEEP) YOU WANT.
WE'RE THE EDWARD SCISSORHANDS OF
COUNTRIES.
WE WANT TO LOVE BUT WE ONLY KNOW
HOW TO HURT!